of course with the big game in edmonton
that is the knights and the canucks
they played last night vegas getting the
shutout win
back on the ice tonight how valuable is
it to have two terrific goalies
for situations just like this robin
leonard was terrific the other night
coach deboer giving the reins to mark
andre fleury
who is getting his first start in 15
days
half a month and he's ready knights are
fired up for this one
vegas can go up 3-1 on vancouver if they
get the win that would be huge lots of
knights fans cheering for number 29 in
the first year max patch are ready
his boys here in vegas here in form
patches on the power play it's one
nothing
knights leading now off a 2-1 lead
chandler stevenson scored a goal but
vancouver ties it into no defensive help
look at flower
he is left out to dry knights are
chasing again midway through the second
and the canucks would take a 3-2 lead
it's 3-2 vancouver in the third and
that's when
oh yeah nate schmidt look at this he
just rips one
his sixth career postseason goal it's a
biggie because it's tied another look
boy that gets you going how about the
game-winning goal gotta show you that
one here it is ready for vegas has
carlson on his left
moves in drops it off to the trailer
back in front
they score 4-3 vegas
that's already crashing the net but all
the knights with two goals
they're in the third period to regain
the lead and they weren't done vegas
scoring three goals in five minutes 37
seconds in fact
they scored three goals on five shots
those knights rolling
four lines wearing down the canadian
team marc-andre fleury solid
as expected hey he's a hall of famer why
not max pacioretti
two goals and an assist shay theodore
two assists vegas wins it five
three taking a 3-1 series lead game five
is coming up on tuesday we knew that
we're gonna see their best tonight
uh we felt good about our five on five
play when we run into penalty trouble we
uh you know not only give them
opportunities to score on the power play
but kind of lose our rhythm and our mojo
so
we're able to find it again uh in the
third period and you know a lot of guys
stepped up tonight and played a really
good game the luxury of being able to
put flower in tonight
and get a game out of him like we did
flower's a big part of our room
even if he's not starting he's a huge
part of our room so when he gets in
there you know
you guys are pretty pretty fire episode
back to back and also it's a playoff
game
you know that there's no hiccup between
you know when he jumps in the net from
robin from the night before
all right vegas one